Hey, David.
I like most of Bernie's policies, but I don't
like burning everyone.
I know that has met
him, I says, he's a dick.
Okay, I wonder who you know that as matter.
I also don't want a nearly 80 year old leading
the Progressive Movement.
He has to stop saying he's
a democratic socialist.
It'll never work.
Does the Progressive Movement need a re­brand?
Your question implies a sort of similar understanding
to some of the analysis I made after Super
Tuesday, and what that analysis was included.
The realization that something like Medicare
for All
the left is split on Medicare for all.
You have people who simply don't want it...
You have people
who do want it, but not at the exclusion of
being able to keep private insurance.
There's a lot of
different opinions about Medicare for all
on the left.
My belief is that many elements 75, 80% of
Medicare, for all most of the Left would come
around
to, if it was given to them by the right candidate
and framed in the right way and not presented
as
what you have will be taken away, but rather
this will be created and you can choose to
take
advantage of this or if you wanna keep paying
for insurance, you can do it.
But we are going to
fund this in the following way, as Bernie
is pointed out.
Okay, in a...
I don't think it's crazy to say that when
you hear it from a nearly 80 year old Democratic
Socialist
from Brooklyn, if you are a North Florida
Democrat, you were more likely to be repelled
by it than
to welcome in.
This is not my view understand, I don't care
about Bernie's identity, and I'm doing
the best that I can to look at the policies,
but I understand that there are a lot of people
who would
be in favor of 80% of bones, Medicare for
All plan.
And is free college plan, assuming that it's
the
version that includes trade school, and so
on.
The policies themselves are certainly more
popular than it might appear from the overwhelming
way, in which Joe Biden has outperformed Bernie
in the popular vote in the Democratic primary.
03/13/20 Page 14 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
So, yeah, I completely understand what you're
saying now, as far as whether the progressive
movement needs to re­brand, I'm less sure
about that.
One of the concerns I've expressed is when
I
see people defying politicians almost like...
Like God, like deities I don't care who it
is.
I think that
that's a problem, right?
You have a movement in this country it's probably
about 60 or 70% of Trump supporters that see
Trump as a pseudo­deity.
They see him almost like a God, He can do
no wrong, he can shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue whatever.
I think that that's absolutely terrible.
I've pointed out before,
there are elements of this in the Democratic
Party as well.
I would say anecdotally, from the emails
I got I had tools, supporters Andrew Yang
supporters and Bernie supporters who really
seemed to
see the three respective candidates, as almost
perfect beings as almost they are defying
them in
some way.
And I don't know if it's because I've met
enough of these politicians that I just don't
get sucked into
the cult of personality or whatever, but these
are just people, these are flawed people,
they all have
some good ideas and some ideas that are not
so good, you can like nine out of 10 policies
from one
person and you can still recognize maybe that
10th out of 10 policy doesn't make sense.
Or does the
numbers don't balance or whatever the case
may be?
And when I see anyone defying a candidate,
I
get concerned because I don't think that we
should be defying politicians at all.
There's a very emotional reaction to Bernie
among some of the supporters that reminds
me of some
of the emotional reaction that we see with
Donald Trump and I remember I support the
vast
majority of Bernie's policies and we've been
supporting him on the program for a while.
That doesn't mean that I see Bernie as the
blend, all in terms of the Progressive Movement,
I think
that the way that the progressive movement
will succeed is not necessarily a re­brand,
but it's
number one.
You gotta stop the Democratic Socialist stuff.
I've been talking about that for a very,
very long time.
I know there's part of the Progressive Movement
that likes to say socialism pulls
better than it has in decades.
It still doesn't pull that well, and it's
still not a good idea to be talking
about when the policies you're advocating
aren't actually democratic socialist policies,
there's no
upside.
So whether it's a rebrand or whether it's
picking candidates that may be better relate
to
people demographically or whatever the case,
my...
Is it AOC.
I don't know, maybe...
Maybe not, I
don't know, does she call herself a democratic
socialist?
I'm not sure but what you have to look at
is
in a way, it's crazy.
Look at what the Tea Party did in 2010, the
Tea Party with terrible policies that
were genuinely back for the vast majority
of the people that supported the party candidates
built a
pseudo Movement, which was then integrated
into the Republican Party, and move the entire
party
in that direction.
You're not seeing that happen in the same
way with the progressive movement.
And I don't know, it
pains me to see it not happen.
I don't know if it's the people, I don't believe
that it's the policies, I think the policies
are good, it
may be the framing or the language around
some of the policies.
I'm going to be thinking about this
a lot and talking about it at once we get
past the primary phase, but I'd be curious
to hear from you,
for sure.